tywin walker made his first start as a
blue jay against this baltimore oriole
ball club on the 29th of august and he
picked up a win in that outing
there's a great looking fastball over
the outside corner one down
austin hayes has been hot in the month
of september really swinging the man
well that time he took a good fastball
on the outside quarter walker gets the
first out on a strikeout jorge lopez's
numbers on the year pretty impressive
that's coming over with the o's couple
wins got back-to-back quality starts the
earned run average continues to come
down beau had a big rbi double last
night to drive in biggio at the time
gave the blue jays a two to nothing lead
and he gets a breaking ball that he hits
fair and it's off the umpire and that
ball is still in play because the
umpire's stationed behind the infielder
that is the 97th career hit for boba
shed the jays come up in the bottom of
the second jorge lopez to face randall
gretchen
as grichik sends a fly ball deep left
field
and gone way out of here for randall
bridging his 18th career home run
against the baltimore orioles blue jays
great job hitting in this ballpark base
is loaded for danny jansen and he sends
it to right field a base hit and that'll
get a run home stopping at third on the
play is davis and isn't it nice to see
danny jansen swinging the bat well
vr with a fly ball to center field
mullins setting up to make the catch
tagging is davis and he'll come into
scores the throw comes into third and
the blue jays take a three to nothing
lead
town of vr's had two good advance he
lined out to the third baseman his first
time up and here he hits a sack fly pick
up just his fifth rbi since joining the
blue jays beau buchette who had a base
hit his first time up
and that's gonna get through man alberto
not moving so well
and another run will come in to score
panic in on the rbi single by bichette
and it's four to nothing
um bow's got two hits and that'll give
him 98 hits for his career closing in on
100 base hits and the blue jays with a
four run second inning and now the ninth
blue jay to come to the plate is te
oscar hernandez but two more runners in
scoring position
and this one is driven into left center
and down for a base hit and two more
runs will come in to score fernandez
with a two-run single it is six to
nothing that'll give him 34 rbis with a
season that leads the team
and that wild pitch is costly for the
orioles two runners are going to come in
to score jansen first and then brochett
right behind him
what an inning randall grisham got it
started
jonathan davis has had his moments a
two-run home run against jay happ he had
a two-run double in philadelphia
and he grounds one up the middle for a
base hit guerrero will make the turn
he's coming home he'll score without a
throw and it's seven to nothing they
play pretty well when they're relaxed
when the pressure of the pennant race is
on and that will be all for lopez seven
nothing early blue jays thomas eshelman
on for the orioles in relief and they're
runners on it first and second and there
is still no one out
down the left field line and this ball
is going to drop
davis is on his way home and he will
slide in safely to make it eight to
nothing
boy what a hit parade
eight runs and it's the third inning
blue jays have 11 hits and the air gets
into the act he had a sack fly his last
time up and another good throw from the
left feeling this is an important moment
here for the blue chase in the last few
days they've got a few things they want
to figure out and nate pearson is one of
them he hasn't pitched since the 18th of
august against this oriole ball club
that happened in baltimore he certainly
got austin hayes attention
101 and he just struck out hayes on
three pitches all set up by that first
fastball down and this is 101 miles an
hour and with two strikes it's tough to
lay off
travis shaw steps the plate
shaw with a fly ball to right field and
this one is gone
travis shaw with his second hit of the
night it's a two run homer
yamaguchi faces ramona ureas
that's hit well not right field and
that's gone
out of the house for ramon urias his
first homer of the year and the orioles
are on the board
oh mullins with a drive
that one's way back and gone back to
back ureas with his first major league
home run and cedric mullins with his
third of the season jumped it jose
iglesias will kick things off in the
sixth inning that's it well way back in
left field and this is gone so all of a
sudden a little power surge
from the orioles as a glaciers back to
back nights the long ball for him yeah
how about that hauntzer alberto for two
couple of fly balls the one-two fastball
hit past the dive of the third baseman
panic and it rolls towards the left
field corner it's up against the blue
wall ruiz waved around third throw to
the plate by buchet is high backed up by
burucky he fires to third and alberto
makes it in there safely alberto with an
rbi double he gets to third on the throw
and the orioles are within six it is ten
to four now patrick murphy will make his
third appearance of the season in step
cedric mullins
hit hard on the ground but right to the
second baseman vr
two down i think one of the things that
got him started was his ability to drop
some buns down hits make you feel good i
mean they're all the same and they all
make you feel just as good blue jayson
out away from going to 31 and 27 on the
season fastball and a bouncer to short
backhanded by bichette and the blue jays
will win it they go to 31 and 27 on the
season shaw with a big game richik hit a
home run of the game everybody's feeling
pretty good about things right now jay's
win the first of three final series of
the season against the orioles